good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this fourth and final lecture in the
Stimson lecture series on britain and
europe in a troubled world by Vernon
Bogdan or I should say that it's just
been a real treat to listen to these
lectures I should congratulate myself on
having the presidents to have invited
him at this juncture in the history of
the relationship which I will happily do
and but the the thing to say despite the
incredible richness of Professor Bogdan
ORS knowledge about the British and
European relationship he is a thinker of
astonishing range and you can find this
out not only from reading his large
numbers of books but he if you google in
my upon YouTube you will discover an
astonishing menu of lectures that he has
given on subjects related to British
politics and they are amazing lectures
you'll see today that he is platonic
form of a lecturer incarnate but he has
a tremendous series of lectures for
example on British political party six
lectures he has a tremendous series of
lectures on crises in British history he
has another one called
making the weather six six prominent
British politicians who did not become
Prime Minister but who he illustrates in
those lectures arguably had more impact
on the course of British politics than
politicians who did become Prime
Minister
he has another series on British
monarchs since Victoria all six really
excellent excellent lectures and you can
you can watch them you can as I do play
them on audio books
and it's just an absolute pleasure to to
educate oneself from such an erudite and
incisive speaker and this of course is
to say nothing of his vast scholarly
career at Oxford and elsewhere so this
fourth and final lecture will this will
these four books these will come out as
with the other Simpson lectures
eventually as a book from the Yale
University Press in the next year or so
in in in due course and we will make
certain that we use the date of its
publication as an excuse to bring
Professor Bogdan over back and we will
have a workshop on the book so you can
all come back again and revisit some of
these issues so that the the fourth and
final lecture is called a never closer
Union does Europe have a future
professor Bogdan or welcome thank you
[Applause]
well thank you Ian but I have to say
that each introduction has embarrassed
me more than the previous one
now this lecture is about the future of
Europe and that involves understanding
the European Union which is not an easy
task and Madeline Albright who I believe
is coming to Yale tomorrow once said
that understand the European Union you
have to be a genius or French now sadly
I'm neither but I will do my best
it is clear that brexit poses a
challenge to the European Union because
it must be a blow to an international
organization when one of its largest and
most powerful members decides that it
wishes to leave and it challenges the
standard European Union narrative of
ever closer Union and so threatens what
might be called the ideology of the
European
now so far I have spoken as if brexit is
a British aberration as if it reflects
factors peculiar to Britain but is that
really the case
or does it reflect anxieties which are
held also in other member states in the
European Union some of the leaders of
the European Union do not regard brexit
as a peculiarly British aberration
Donald Tusk president of the European
Council believed even before the brexit
referendum that Europe needed to take a
long hard look at itself and listen to
the British warning signals and then
shortly after the referendum at
Bratislava in September 2016 just three
months after the referendum he said this
it would be a fatal error to assume that
the negative result in the UK referendum
were represents a specifically British
issue that British Euroskeptic ism is a
symbol of political aberration or merely
a cynical game of populist s' exploiting
social frustrations the brexit vote is a
desperate attempt to answer the question
that millions of Europeans ask
themselves daily questions about the
guarantees of security of the citizens
and their territory questions about the
protection of their interests cultural
heritage and way of life these are
questions we would have to face even if
Britain had voted to remain president
Macker all of France
was candid enough to admit in a
television interview on BBC early in
2017 that the anxieties felt in Britain
which had led to brexit were also
present in many other European countries
indeed he went on to say that if a
referendum were to be held in France on
that country
continual membership he could not
guarantee that the outcome would be
positive other European leaders must
surely concede that some of the anti
European sentiment is not exclusively
British but is present across Europe as
a whole therefore brexit should not be
regarded as a specifically British
aberration but a symptom of wider
problems and tensions faced by the
European Union as a whole in particular
recent crises over the Euro and
migration have revealed deep
deficiencies in the structure of the
European Union
sometimes summed up in the phrase the
Democratic deficit the European Union
has been described by the Italian
political scientist and Sergio fabrini
as being like the United States a
compound Republic and what he means by a
compound Republic is a political system
divided not only territorially along
federal lines but with a division of
powers at the centre in the United
States obviously between the President
Congress and Supreme Court in Europe
between the council the commission of
Parliament and a European Court of
Justice of course there are many
differences between the European Union
and the United States though I think
it's more sensible to compare those two
political systems than it is to compare
the United States with Britain or Canada
or or Germany for example now the
European Union unlike America has no
army and no police force it's public
expenditure is minimal comprising just
1.0 3% of the gross national product of
the member states perhaps the European
Union might be compared not with the
United States as it is today but the
United States as it was in 1787 with no
federal income tax a Senate was not
directly elected and an unwillingness to
project its power upon
world but there's one crucial difference
the European Union is a free association
of states which explicitly recognizes in
article 50 of the treaty agreed at
Lisbon in 2008 the right of secession a
writer which Britain is currently taking
advantage that right of secession was
not even granted as I understand it in
the Articles of Confederation which
precedes the Federal Constitution much
less in the Federal Constitution itself
because as I understand the Articles of
Confederation were entitled Articles of
Confederation and perpetual union
between the states and there is a
further vital difference between
European Union and the American system
of government in the European Union the
Commission is the only body that is
given the right of a legislative
initiative now in Britain and in
countries influenced by the British
parliamentary tradition the power of a
legislative initiative is seen as the
political power to be exercised only by
those who are elected and not by
appointed or unaccountable officials
there is in Britain as in Canada
Australia and New Zealand a fairly
strict separation of powers by means of
which political power lies in the hands
of those elected accountable to
Parliament and removable by the people
with a minimal exception in Britain of a
very small number of Ministers in the
House of Lords now officials by contrast
civil servants are not elected they are
non partisan and accountable to
ministers but not to the voters they
cannot be removed by the voters
but they serve whatever government is
chosen by the voters and they cannot
make political decisions the British do
not understand the Continental
conception of the unelected politician
or the elected official I once heard a
Conservative MP at a meeting address a
member of the
mission the mates thin gondola as an
official mr. gondola bristled and I
imagine drag dolor would have bristled
even more being called an official but
the British find it difficult to
comprehend how a non-elected person can
enjoy such wide powers now the
Commission has admittedly become weaker
since the end of the reign of Raptor law
the most activist president the
Commission has ever known and there have
been attempts to make it more
accountable the Commission now needs the
approval of the Parliament before it
takes office but the Parliament in
itself seen as is the Commission as part
of an alienated superstructure most
European citizens continue to give their
main allegiance to their member states
the legislators of their member states
while European Parliament elections
attract and arise in return out and are
generally decided not on European issues
but domestic issues
and many politicians call them second
order issues because the issues normally
or not how do you think the European
Union should develop but what do you
think of your national government there
pleb is it's on the national government
ironically there will be one exception
to this if Britain takes part in the
European palms elections next month
because they will be only a European
issue namely the question of whether
breath it should be carried out or
whether it should be reversed it will be
in a sense a second referendum on the
European issue but that is unusual but
the European Parliament broadly speaking
is seen not as representing the people
but as part of the political class not
us but them an attempt was made in the
2014 appointment of the Commission to
provide democratic legitimacy to it
through the so called spits in candidate
process the lead candidate process and
by this process each party grew
being in the European Parliament would
nominate its candidate for president of
the Commission before the European
Parliament elections and then the party
which won the most seats would have the
right to have its candidate appointed as
president and that led to Ron Claude
Younker former prime minister of
Luxembourg and head of the European
People's Party which is a Christian
Democrat grouping becoming president but
few in Europe had heard of a Yunker
before the election and is difficult to
believe that those who voted for the
European People's Party were conscious
of supporting him for the post of
commission president at the time of
writing it appears that the European
People's Party candidate for the next
president will be Manfred Weber leader
of that party in the European Parliament
since not 2014 but I suspect that even
fewer in Europe have heard of Manfred
Weber then have heard of jean-claude
Juncker so the problem of the Democratic
deficit cannot be resolved through this
method and indeed the problem is
inherent in the conception of European
integration held by Jean Monnet the
founder of the European Union now male
was a great man who understood European
unity was not - achieved by mere
goodwill but required common policies
and common institutions male however
exercises inference from behind the
scenes he never in his life held any
elected position perhaps for this reason
he never fully appreciated that
political legitimacy is secured
primarily by direct election a principle
fundamental to the British conception of
representative government the epigraph
to the memoirs of zom on a declare we
are not forming coalition's between
states but union among people but the
people he had in mind were the elites
who would construct Europe by stealth
using economic means to lock the
nation-states together without the prose
without the people as a whole being
aware of the process until it had become
irreversible he hoped to achieve a
united Europe almost by stealth
without the people noticing it the
European Union urgently needs dat in
front its democratic deficit European
integration from the time of the Coal
and Steel community to the European
Union agreed at Maastricht in 1990 to
have been developed by elites with
little popper involvement that was
understandable in the immediate post-war
years when there was great distrust of
the people because of the experience of
mass support for fascism Nazism and
collaboration but it is no longer
feasible in his Sorbonne speech in 2017
in which he laid down a framework for
the future of Europe president Mackrell
said the founding fathers built European
isolation of the people because they
were an enlightened vanguard but he then
went on to say European Democratic doubt
put an end to that chapter chapter and I
think we were wrong to move Europe
forward in spite of the people we must
stop being afraid of the people we must
simply stopped building Europe in
isolation from them the institutions of
the European Union were constructed in
the 1950s at a time when deference
towards elected leaders and officials
was much greater than it is today the
structure of the Coal and Steel
community and European communities out
of which European Union has grown was
based very much on the ethos of the
French fourth republic in which as a
result of the weakness of the political
executive and the instability of
successive governments considerable
powers accrued to unelected officials
the commissar ER general new plant
formed in 1946 whose first head was
Rahman a enjoyed enjoyed wide powers
over the economy and was intended to
represent the
general interest as opposed to the
parties an interest of the politicians
but it was appointed and not elected
mone believed that the Commission which
he origin also the first head should
also be appointed and all similarly to
represent the general interests of
Europe rather than the particular
interests of the Member States indeed
John mone and other founding fathers of
European unity actually in visited the
Commission as a provisional government
of Europe and eventually the real
government of Europe
with the European Parliament as a lower
house and the Council of Ministers
representing the Member States as an
upper house analogous to the German
upper house the bundesrat which
represents the various governments of
the lender now such a conception might
have been possible with six closely
connected member states it is utterly
implausible in a sprawling european
union of twenty eight surely shortly to
be twenty seven states in france the
fourth republic system by which
unelected officials enjoyed considerable
power as a result of the weakness of the
political executive was replaced by the
go lists in the fifth republic by a
system of strong government so while the
european council composed of the
governments of the Member States and the
European Parliament are seen by many as
remote from those who may represent the
Commission is inherently remote the
problem can be resolved as the French go
lists have suggested by bringing the
Commission under the control of the
European Council which represents the
Member States the council would then be
clearly seen as the executive of the
European Union while the Commission
would become the Secretariat of the
Council and would lose the power to
initiate legislation such a reform will
do much to undermine euro scepticism
which thrives on the anatomy of an
unaccountable body of official
exercising legislative power something
which the British have found
particularly difficult to accept now in
her brewed lecture of 2010 as
significant in its way as American
Thatcher's better known lecture in 1988
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel
emphasized that there were two methods
of European integration the first was
the community method that of
supranational ISM what might be called a
Monet or Schumann or dolor method but
that was not the only method of European
integration
there was also what she called the Union
method of coordinated action by national
governments Europe she insisted what to
be built by both methods and not solely
by the community method which had been
too much emphasized that was a sanitary
warning the community method has
certainly continued with a gradual
deepening of the European Union in many
errors and are hardly noticed by the
general public for example harmonization
in the regulation of drugs and this has
led to an an inter weaving and indeed
interpenetration of the economic and
even the social systems of the Member
States and the difficulties of the
brexit process show how how
extraordinary difficult it is to
disentangle a Member State after 46
years of membership but a delicate
balance is needed between the two
methods of supranational and the
intergovernmental if that balance is
upset and these super national methods
in trenches upon national identities
there will be popular resistance and the
problems aroused by the if migration
crisis show in graphic form how the
European Union can run into serious
difficulties if it goes beyond what is
acceptable by
seeming to challenge the national
identity of the member states and the
eurozone crisis and the migration crisis
have been confronted primarily by the
governments of the member states in the
European Council with the Commission and
the European Parliament playing a
distinctly subordinate role but Moni
Schumann the law conception of Europe
which was responsible for the early
successes of European unity is now
coming to appear moribund indeed as long
ago as 1990 when the law told the
European Parliament at Strasbourg that
he wanted Europe to become I quote a
true Federation by the Millennium French
president Francois Amitabha watching his
speech on television burst out but
that's ridiculous what's he up to no one
in Europe will ever want that by playing
the extremists he's going to wreck
what's achievable there is no concrete
intention in Europe to build a federal
super state whatever that means except
in rhetorical declarations it is indeed
difficult to discover any Frenchman or
French woman any in German or Italian
who wishes to submerge his or her
national identity in Europe instead they
seek to pursue their own national
interest constructively within an
international cooperative European
framework perhaps Britain should have
done the same so the European Union will
remain despite integration for the
foreseeable future primarily an
intergovernmental institution in which
the member states dictate the pace of
change it will remain what the goal
called
in Europe des ATAR but the EU is an
intergovernmental organization with a
difference since the member states learn
to consider not only their own interests
but the interests of your
as a whole the continent has suffered in
the past from the absence of such an
internationalist perspective
had it been present in 1914 had the
states of Europe considered the
interests of the continent as a whole
rather than purely their own national
interests war would probably have been
avoided now in Britain the brexit has
made much of the dangers of an
overweening Europe and a federal super
state but it's clear that most of the
member states are no longer prepared to
sacrifice much more of their sovereignty
the European Union has become
economically politically and culturally
too diverse for a further drive towards
ever closer Union to be feasible it will
remain for the foreseeable future an
association of states committed as a
British Liberal Democrat former member
of the european parliament and
federalist andrew goth lamented it'll be
committed to never closer union
ironically from this point of view
brexit Britain and gorlice France could
be said to be in the vanguard of
European development and not hindrances
to it because they appreciated long
before other countries what the
sacrifice of sovereignty actually meant
in practice Britain thanks to her long
evolutionary history and the go lists as
a result of French experiences during
the Second World War when in the 1990s
Prime Minister John Major together with
other British leaders declared that
Europe was not yet ready for a common
currency his warnings were ignored and
he was regarded as an obfuscator
but perhaps the other member states
would have done well to listen to his
warnings that would certainly be the
view of those young people in the
Mediterranean member states who find
themselves unemployed
the result of the austerity policies
Nessus neset ated by the common currency
some of the other member states
especially those which had recently
emerged from dictatorships did not fully
appreciate what the sacrifices
sovereignty would mean in practice it
was easy for them to say rhetorically
that they were in favor of it but now we
find that Germany when it comes to a
transfer union that is the sharing of
debts Greece when it comes to budgetary
restrictions and the visit grad
countries of Central Europe the Czech
Republic Hungary Poland and Slovakia
when it comes to accepting their new
quota of Syrian migrants they find that
their acceptance of shared sovereignty
is subject to very strict limits the
British together with legality in France
have always been profoundly skeptical of
the integrationist project and their
skepticism has been borne out by reality
it is the goal and not la moune who is
the prophet of today's Europe and
perhaps it was for this reason that the
great French novelist Antrim algo who
served him to Gold government said that
the goal was a man of the day before
yesterday and the day after tomorrow if
the European Union faces a democratic
deficit it also faces a defence deficit
it is the only one of the four major
power groupings in the world the others
being the United States Russia and China
which is unable to defend itself but
remains dependent upon an outside power
the United States and this was not
intended when the NATO organization was
set up in February 1951
shortly after NATO was founded its first
supreme commander of General Eisenhower
a friend if in ten years all American
troops stationed in Europe for national
defense purposes have not been returned
to the United States then this whole
project NATO will have failed and he
insisted that America and I quote cannot
be a modern Rome guarding the frontiers
with our legions but apparently at the
signing ceremony of a NATO alliance the
band played George Gershwin song it
ain't necessarily so America currently
contributes around 72% of NATO's defense
spending Europe must take greater steps
to defend itself that is demand note
only a president chump it would almost
certainly have also been the plea of
Hillary Clinton had she been elected
though she might have expressed her view
in different tones because there's
almost certainly a trend in American
policy independent of who is elected to
the White House to press Europe to bear
more of the costs of her own defense
in addition America is becoming more
interested in the Asia Pacific area that
is a development that preceded the
election of Donald Trump and will almost
certainly continue after his presidency
there is therefore a strong case for
NATO to become a two pillar alliance
with a strengthened European pillar and
the European Union has indeed been
seeking to expand its role in the area
of security and defence it seeks what it
calls strategic autonomy though it is
never very clear precisely what that
means but in February 2015
Ursula Van der Leyen the German defense
minister called for a European army and
that call was echoed in March 2015 by
jean-claude Juncker who said that a
European army would convey to Russia
that we are serious about defending the
values of the European Union and of
course pressure for greater cooperation
has been given impetus
by the fear that European defence and
security may no longer be underpinned by
the United States and that unconditional
American support for Europe can no
longer be taken for granted and perhaps
this audience in particular may find it
very striking that nearly 75 years after
the end of the Second World War
Europe remained so dependent upon the
United States for its defense and
security but in foreign and defense
policy the EU is likely to move towards
further intergovernmentalism rather than
integration indeed proposals for a
common European foreign and defence
policy might prove dangerous since they
could yield high sounding aspirations
which come to mean little when tested
against reality and that was the fate
that befell the League of Nations
between the wars it was full of fine
phrases with regard to collective
security and mutual solidarity but when
tested by the Italian invasion of
Abyssinia in 1935 it fell to pieces a
rules-based order clearly needs
sanctions if it is be effective as a
Hobbes said in Leviathan covenants
without swords are about words and of no
strength to secure a man at all and this
was also a lesson which Americans drew
from the failure of collective security
in the 1930s Henry Stimson in whose
honor these lectures are being held
seems to have wanted to implement
sanctions against Japan following her
attack on Manchuria in 1931 but his
President Herbert Hoover certainly did
not
and perhaps sanctions were not practical
at that time but Stimson and his
disciples certainly drew the lesson that
something stronger was needed after 1945
if the post-war world was to enjoy
genuine security now Britain which has
the world's fifth largest defense budget
and is with France a preeminent European
contributor to NATO has always been
skeptical of an integrated European
defense policy and with good reason
since she believes that such a policy if
effective would undermine NATO it would
at the very least involved a version of
energy which would be better applied to
strengthening NATO but the general
British view is that is unlikely to
prove effective the problem with an
integrated European defense policy is
that it could in theory require as the
League of Nations did that a country
would be committed to go to war against
the wishes of its own government and
Parliament while if military action
required unanimity and currently
decisions on defence and foreign policy
do require unanimity in the European
Union every one of 27 members would have
a veto and that would be a guarantee
that in the absence of American or
British leadership nothing would be done
moreover in the major foreign policy
crises of the last two decades
for example the action in Kosovo and the
Iraq war Europe found itself divided the
truth is that for effective defence the
units to be defended must see their
separate interests are subordinated to a
common good this might prove to be the
case in Europe at some future date but
it is not there today and it cannot be
created artificially by politicians or
officials by simply providing a label of
a European defence policy it requires a
fundamental Allegiance and commitment to
the unit that is to be defended and
therefore there's a strong case for NATO
to become a two pillar alliance with a
strengthened European
intergovernmental pillar soccer pillar
is hardly possible without Britain one
of two nuclear powers in Europe in 2014
it was agreed that all NATO members
would seek to spend two percent of their
GDP on defense in 2014 but Britain is at
present one of just seven of NATO's 29
member states to meet that target
she was a second larger spender on
defense in the organization behind only
the United States Germany not only has
not reached a NATO target of two percent
of defense spending she has not even
reached her own target of 1.5% her
defense spending being around 1.2
percent and all this casts doubt on the
possibility of franco-german leadership
of Europe here too we have to
distinguish between rhetoric and reality
in January of this year the two
countries signed a treaty that Arkan
seat of the Carolingian Emperor
Charlemagne you this not only had
provisions for greater economic
cooperation but it provided the
establishment of a franco-german
Security Council with the Evangel aim of
creating a European army and since the
time of de Gaulle who would sign an
earlier treaty with German Chancellor
Konrad Adenauer in 1963 the
franco-german relationship has been
based on what the French regard was a
complementarity of interests France
assumed it would have the political and
defence leadership of Europe while
Germany would provide the economic
weight but radical move towards tighter
integration on the part of France and
Germany appear unlikely because they are
at odds on the idea of a coordinated
economic policy Germany being adamant
that she cannot accept a European budget
if that means a transfer Union by means
of which she is required to subsidize
what she regards as feckless
Mediterranean States further and more
important Germany for reasons connected
with her history can only be a purveyor
of soft power
she cannot become a major power in a
foreign policy and defense it had been
objections on the part of the Bundestag
the lower house of the
and legislature which prevented a
European response to the civil war in
Syria the Trump administration has been
pressing Germany to be more visible in
the defense of Poland and it took a long
time for Germany to support intervention
in Mali in 2013 while eight NATO allies
took part in intervention in Libya in
2011 Germany restricted herself to naval
operations constitutional restrictions
prevented her from participating in
Bosnia in the 1990s and she's unwilling
to take part in the French initiative
for a euro Corps in Africa which has too
many echoes or Rommels Afrika Corps in
1952 Harold Macmillan very prescient lee
remarked the French are frightened of
the Germans the Germans are frightened
of themselves a senior British Foreign
Office diplomat told me he'd said to his
German counterpart brexit we'll make you
more powerful than ever
yes was the reply but even less willing
and less able to use that power to the
extent that Germany is a hegemonic power
in the post brexit European Union she is
a reluctant hegemon in 2011 tolis
foreign minister Radek Sikorski said he
feared german power less than he feared
german inactivity a former British
ambassador to Berlin has written it is
not Germany which has set out to lead it
as others who have chosen to follow and
therefore it follows that for a genuine
European defence policy the key lies not
in Berlin but in London
now if European defense must be
intergovernmental and if Britain must
play a part in it
it cannot be within a European Union
framework since Britain is leaving the
European Union it must therefore be
outside that framework and that too is
what two-goal believed he believed if
you're opposed to be a power in the
world she had to develop defense
arrangements outside the European Union
that was the basis of his Fouche plan in
1962 and a suggestion in 1969 to the
British ambassador Sir Christopher
Soames that a four-power Directorate be
established comprising Britain France
Germany and Italy to be responsible for
foreign policy and defense but such an
approach was of course quite
inconsistent with another branch of
gaullism which was that Britain was not
fundamentally a European power and it is
inconsistent with the whole tradition of
a fifth republic continued to some
extent by president Makarov of
marginalizing Britain as a power in
Europe France sees brexit solely in
financial and trade terms and not in
geopolitical terms she sees it as an
opportunity for French Business and
Finance that strategy is self-defeating
because the European Union is not only
or even primarily an institution for
economic development a series of linear
processes that need to be protected but
in part a means of strengthening Europe
in the world and for that Britain is
essential so France must appreciate that
if a liberal Europe is to defend itself
a revival of the ant ant is essential
that ant ant had been abandoned when
Britain refused to join the iron steel
community and France had formed instead
a partnership with Germany but Germany
could never provide the political and
diplomatic leadership
that could have been given by Britain a
renewal of the armed tant would not as
is sometimes perceived in America be an
attempt to push America out of Europe
rather it would be strengthening and
making more credible than NATO
commitment now the European project is
currently in some danger the European
Parliament elections due to be held next
month are likely to result in gains for
the so called populist parties such as
our own Nacional in France alternativa
for Deutschland in Germany the league in
Italy and the Sweden Democrats and if
Britain takes part in these elections
Nigel Ferraris new brexit party which
polls today show is in the lead lead
leads all the parties in Britain in the
projection now these parties apart from
Ferrara's party do not at present want
their country to leave the European
Union but of course they are against
further integration but more important
there were a liberal approach and in
particular their intolerance towards the
minorities lies directly contrary to the
purposes for which the European Union
was established president McConnell
France has declared that the European
Union faces an existential struggle with
the protagonists of vote Viktor Orban
prime minister of Hungary proudly calls
in liberal democracy another name
perhaps for populism all this makes
brexit appear as part of a wider
European crisis rather than a
specifically British aberration
president macro has become the spokesman
of liberal Europe against populist
Europe whose headquarters are in
Budapest and the branch offices are in
Warsaw Bucharest and now Rome but
Britain too despite what I regard as
superficial appearances Britain is also
part of liberal Europe and Britain
brought to Europe the economic
liberalism of Margaret Thatcher whose
credit so matter the impetus towards a
single market belongs
brexit will weaken therefore the forces
of economic liberalism on the continent
and as in the 1930s despite appearances
Britain remains a stronghold of
political liberalism there's a striking
absence in Britain of neo-fascist or
Islamophobic parties able to win
parliamentary support there is no
British equivalent to the from NASA now
the alternativa for Deutschland or the
Swedish Democrats Britain therefore is
part of liberal Europe both in economic
and political terms so breakfast is in
danger of weakening liberal Europe the
balance will be shifted in the direction
of the populist and that is one reason
why it's in the interests of both
Britain and the European Union why
Britain should retain strong ties with
the continent after brexit and why
France should modify her stature her
strategy which began with the goal and
has continued throughout much of the
fifth republic of seeking to marginalize
Britain in Europe the future of liberals
in Europe depends in no small degree on
solidarity between Britain and France
after brexit sadly the British and
French do not always recognize the
importance of removing the current mess
on towns and reviving the Anton's
but the strength and stability of France
and the success of President macron as a
spokesman for liberal Europe hours
matter British interest as a French one
just as the success of post brexit
Britain is a key French interest and the
survival of a liberal Europe based on
the rule of law is also an American
interest as the whole history of the
20th century shows because if the
European Union disintegrated it would in
my view be a tragedy not just for Europe
but also for Britain that is out of
Europe and also for the world of the
whole because as I said in my first
lecture the European Union began not as
an economic project nor as a federal
project but a peace project
and in 1949 or Bayer Schumann said it
Strasburg we are carrying out a great
experiment the fulfillment of the same
recurrent dream that for ten centuries
has revisited the peoples of Europe
creating between them an organization
putting an end to war and guaranteeing
an eternal peace and the first step of
course was to lock the economies of
France and Germany together so the two
countries should never go to war again
that aim has long been achieved in 2018
France Timmerman's vice-president of the
European Commission and a former Dutch
foreign minister showed his 12-year old
daughter the anti-tank defenses at the
frontier with Germany where his
grandparents had cheered the Allied
bombing of often during the war he said
this is part of the border and his
daughter looked at him and said daddy
what is a border and even if the
European Union were now to break up of
course France and Germany would remain
securely at peace but a secure peace has
not been achieved everywhere everywhere
in Europe by any means in particular it
has not been achieved in the Western
Balkans where ancient hatreds threaten
the stability of the region and when
Yugoslavia broke up in 1991 at Booth's
Luxembourg's Foreign Minister declared
it is the hour of Europe it is not the
hour of the Americans yet Europe
appeared impotent to prevent the ethnic
cleansing and Muslims in Bosnia and
Kosovo the worst crimes that Europe has
seen since the Holocaust it was left in
NATO and primarily Britain and America
to intervene in Kosovo and intervention
which led rapidly to the fall of Serbian
President Slobodan Milosevic and the
independence of Kosovo and the failure
of Europe in the 1990s severely damaged
its moral credibility in the Western
Balkans most of all warring neighbors
need a common home in that part of
Europe membership of the European Union
seemed the only way in which
old conflicts and be overcome and this
came to me with particular force and
gave me a new perspective on the
European Union when in 2006 I was asked
to assist in the drafting of a
constitution for Kosovo our meetings
were held not in Kosovo itself since
those members of the Slav minority in
Kosovo who were prepared to participate
insisted on meeting in Slav territory so
we met in Skopje the capital of what was
then Macedonia that is now called
northern Macedonia I had never before
seen such national hatreds on display
the conflict in Kosovo made the quarrel
in northern islands appear almost
manageable and the conflict when
Yugoslavia broke up offers a terrible
warning of what could happen in the
Europe that is once more broken up into
national states indeed one important
factor perhaps the prime factor
preventing open warfare between Muslims
and Slavs between Kosovo and Serbia was
the desire of both countries to join the
European Union and it was made clear to
Serbia that her prospects of membership
depended upon establishing a
relationship with Kosovo in 2013
agreements were reached with the EU on
such matters as bilateral trade cotta
those participation in regional
initiatives and the status of the Slav
minority in Kosovo the enlargement
strategy report of the European
Commission declared the historic
agreement reached by Serbia and Kosovo
in April is further proof of the power
of the European Union perspective and
its role in healing histories deep scars
the European Union has in the Balkans
become a roof over the warring
nationalities as the austro-hungarian
Empire endeavored to be in the years
before 1914 stability of the Balkans is
of course is important to Britain as it
is of the continent and it was after all
in the Balkans that the great
catastrophe of the 20th century began in
1914 dragging both Britain and the
United States into war
I return at the end of these lectures to
Henry Stimson he was a leading architect
of the post-war international order
underpinned by American leadership he
and those who followed him men such as
Marshall and Addison were profoundly
conscious of the fragility of that order
they had seen it destroyed not just by
one but by two ruinous world wars the
same perception animated those European
leaders who thought he united Europe
after 1945 men such as Winston Churchill
Konrad Adenauer and Robert Schumann
international order had broken down in
1914 when the first world war called by
George Kennan the seminal catastrophe of
the 20th century broke out before that
Europe had known almost a hundred years
of peace broken only by local wars which
had not involved confrontation between
the great powers people had taken peace
for granted under estimating the
fragility of a balance of power which
sustained it Europe could so some
believed in 1914 easily survived a short
war directed against a small
recalcitrant state Serbia in the words
of that great diplomatic historian AJP
Taylor all thought that war could be
fitted into the existing framework of
civilization war was expected to
interrupt the even tenor of civilian
life only while it lasted the British
Foreign Secretary Edward gray told the
House of Commons if we are engaged in
war we shall suffer but little more than
we shall suffer if we stand aside when
in 1914 the Austrian socialist victor
Adler told Oscars Foreign Minister that
war would provoke revolution in Russia
and perhaps even in the Habsburg Empire
itself the Foreign Minister Leopold from
birth talk report retorted and who will
lead this revolution perhaps mr.
Bronstein sitting over there
a central well mr. Bronstein turned out
to be Leon Trotsky and he did indeed
lead a revolution the chain of events
which began with the murder of the
Austrian Archduke in Sarajevo those to
encompass all was the whole of the 20th
century ending only with the collapse of
communism in the Soviet Union in 1989
and from the ruins of the consonant the
founding fathers began the process of
European integration and it was as I
have said constructed by a generation
all too conscious of the dangers of a
breakdown of international order
but now as that generation which either
entered the Second World War or which
understands it as part of its historical
memory has disappeared so also there has
disappeared that sense of the fragility
of international order which the
immediate post-war generation understood
so well now as in the years before 1914
there are siren voices saying that the
international order would benefit from a
shake-up and that any disturbance to it
could be kept well under control that
was the view of the Austrian leadership
and the German General Staff in 1914
they were wrong then and their successes
the leaders of the liberalism in Europe
are equally wrong today in September
2014 christine lagarde the managing
director of the International Monetary
Fund told a lunch at the Financial Times
that she was particularly concerned
about what she sees as a structural
disconnect between economic and
political structures while the global
economic system was becoming
increasingly integrated the global
political systems fragmenting and
becoming more so because of the backlash
against globalization Lagarde's
interlocutor responded this makes for a
dangerous cocktail since it creates a
world that is interconnected in the
sense that shocks can spread quickly but
nobody's actually in charge and Lagarde
nodded and her playful manner
disappeared
it is not clear which of these trends
will win I am worried very worried I
don't want my chill
my grandchildren to grow up in a world
which is disaggregated and fragmented
and the aim of the European Union is to
ensure we can prevent that world
becoming one which is disaggregated and
fragmented into conflicting national
ethnic groups a world of competing
national states in my first lecture I
suggested that while liberals in the
19th century had welcomed nationalism
their twentieth-century counterparts
sort of transcended in a remarkable
valedictory speech in the European
Parliament in January 1995 just over a
year before his death French president
Francois meteor spoke of his childhood
omits families torn apart by the first
world war who were mourning their dead
and nursing a hatred against their
traditional enemies he spoke of his time
in a German prison camp in the second
world war war he declared was Europe's
past but it is not only Europe's past it
could also be Europe's future and it is
up to us he said to be henceforth the
gardens of peace of security and the
future and he concluded by saying the
Nacional is Uma c'est la guerre
nationalism means war thank you
[Applause]
um Chancellor from here yes well that
you imply vote into for brexit Scotland
did not but the turnout in Scotland was
far lower than the average it was the
second lowest turnout in the country
I think paradoxically brexit makes
Scottish independence a less feasible
proposition because an independent
Scotland will be cut off from the rest
of the UK internal market she would if
she sought to rejoin the European Union
which she would have to do under article
49 she would not get the benefit of the
rebate which Margaret Thatcher
negotiated in Britain in 1984 and she
would have a difficult decision to make
about her currency if she kept the pound
her monetary policy would be decided in
London by a foreign power as it were if
she had her own currency that would
require very high interest rates to keep
money in Scotland but most likely if she
did seek to join the European Union as a
nationalist say they would they would be
legally required to join the euro and
that would mean their budgetary deficit
would have to be 3% of GDP the current
budgetary deficit is around
7% of GDP so it would make our austerity
Chancellor look a bit like Santa Claus
to who think of a policy needed to get
it in order it's also important to note
the National Park Scottish National
Party has been itself riven by the
brexit vote because one third of its
voters supported brexit and for them
brexit is more important than Scottish
independence and it was found in the
2017 election but SNP voters who
supported brexit were much more likely
to defect to the other parties could
brexit was more important than
independence than SNP voters who were
for Britain and a nationalist looms
always in trouble when there's another
cleavage cutting it down the middle on
Northern Ireland Northern Ireland's in
one sense and a more favorable position
because it's been agreed perfectly
sensibly but if Northern Ireland were to
unite with the Republic she would not be
required to join rejoin because she
would become part of an existing member
states as East Germany did with West
Germany and I believe if there was a hot
so called hard border that would
encourage nationalists to support Irish
unity but if there wasn't there's no
evidence would the poll I quoted in May
from May last year it may have changed
since showed 21% support for Irish unity
and even amongst Catholics of 46% and
the favoured option for Catholics is
power-sharing devolution of the kind set
up by the devolution legislation but
possibly Irish unity is more likely than
Scottish independence so they most polls
on the book the Irish don't like being
called a mainland in Britain since the
mid 80s have shown a majority in Britain
that wishes Northern Ireland
wouldn't joke the topic bring the water
back here no I don't you see even if you
take the brexit party for Rajas party
although it may have racialist in it and
the racialist sin possibly all the
parties but I'm in mind you the
strongest racialism is in the labour
party in terms of anti-semitism got
racism
it is not a racialist party and when
Farrar does lead review Kip he would not
allow former members of a British
national party to join his party and it
it's put fall under the new UK which
perhaps has left sorry so slightly
convey is in this lament for weak
parties but it's not doing as well as
Ferrara's party which is in the lead and
so I it's a party the the brexit party
in the form of new Kip is a party which
holds a a very legitimate proposition
that Britain should leave the European
Union and indeed is supported by some
members of ethnic minorities and
whatever you think of Boris Johnson and
the right-wing leadership of the Tory
party or right and potentially they are
not racists or Islamophobes
in the ideological sense or the front
acinar Sweden Democrats or EF Dean's and
so on so
I don't think that there are sometimes
called that Northern Quarter and
although I don't share their view I
think that's very unfair one leader a
normally sensible Labour Party MP last
week referred to Jacob Riis Morgan and
someone else as Nazis which I thought
was really into a dreadful stanza so I
think the political culture remains
unique extremely modern experiencing
macro has raised that really for the
first time in this form in previous
forms a multi-speed Europe meant that
every country reaches the same
destination but at different speed
speeds but macron raised in a different
form I think for the first time namely
that only certain countries should
commit themselves to closing Union
others could remain permanently in an
outside tier and that he said possibly
condescending they could give Britain
the place in Europe in the outside tier
well that perfectly perfectly fares
probably what many British people would
like but then it's true the core might
you might on your view come to some
defense agreement but I don't think
Germany will ever would ever wish to
take a leading part in defence
arrangements whereas Britain obviously
the nuclear power in a very large
defence spenders so I don't think that
would be plausible and III think
proposals for European army are absurd
and
the rhetorical trimethylamine and ask
you to elaborate a little further on the
relations between the first half of the
elective the second so much of the first
part of your lecture was about the the
Democratic deficit in the EU and project
very powerful case you made and Tony
Judd and others have made it that once
it starts to run into crises this
demographic chronic deficits going to
surface and it has and you give chapter
and verse of it and so you argue that it
needs to be repaired on the other hand
you know what we see is part of the
reason the the elite project continues
is is actually fear of the electrics as
you said micron thinks that if the
French had a referendum they might well
vote to leave the is the SPD only
rejoined the Beco in a grand coalition
after seven years of seven months of
failed negotiations with between her and
the greens and
free Democrats because the poll showed
that by then if Germany had another
election the alternative for Deutschland
would do even better I was at a
conference in Belgium not that long ago
/ actually Klaus offer was saying new
people are getting screwed by the
monetary arrangements in the EU you
should leave and the powerful Belgian
response from economists and lawyers was
you know if Belgium left if Belgium left
we would be printing money and out and
democratic system might well collapse I
mean not Belgium Portugal I should have
said Portugal we would collapse and so
they're terrified of their own
electorate and so how do we on the one
hand repair the Democratic deficit to
keep Europe together which you think is
so important but on the other hand in
country after yes it's fair to say as as
I mentioned the populist parties do not
at present because they are responding
as it were to popular opinion they do
not advocate their country should leave
the European Union that may change and
some of them did in the past but I think
the answer the answer to your question
is that Europe has to get the balance
right between what is a responsibility
of national governments and what is not
and on migration it's clear the attempt
to have quotas of migrants has failed
and on the euro that there's no appetite
for what president macron wants which is
in effect to transfer Union the European
economic policy and in don't tusks words
what Europe wants is not more Europe but
better Europe in other words practical
policies that make people appreciate the
advantages of European Union one example
is very clearly
and what again this was in his fed say
it was in macron Sorbonne speech the
completion of a digital marking the
completion of an energy market the
completion of the marketing freedom of
services I mean that is largely
rhetorical if you try and set up as a
solicitor or an architect in France you
will find there is not freedom of
professional services and that could do
a great deal of good and did Marc Rutter
the Dutch Prime Minister when asked what
he thought of the freedom of the
services in Europe he replied a very
similar to Gandhi it would be a very
good idea if we had it and the
completion of that market would do a
tremendous amount of good it's used by
the French particularly from
protectionist purposes long and itis
hammocks and I think by the Germans I
think the training period for
hairdressers in Germany is I think three
or four years so you can't easily set up
ich or in Britain as a hairdresser in
Germany and that that basic part of
internal market hasn't been competing
but create a digital marking from clean
energy market which would lower prices
for Europeans I think would make them
see the practical advantages and I think
Europe is constantly too much on high
flowing rhetorical
declarations on into further integration
and constitutional measures which are
remote from those people it and that's
partly because the Commission is so
remote from public opinion
now I I didn't if I gave the impression
I thought Britain should leave that was
a mistaken impression to give I don't
think Britain should leave
I think Britain should remain what I've
tried to point out throughout these
lectures is that in a sense Britain had
to make more adjustments than any other
country to join because a constitutional
system our electoral system had
political structure all the resumption
in in politics and economics are so
different from the tonton but in my
personal view which sadly was not shared
by the majority of British people we
should have tried to make those
adjustments it was in our interest in in
Europe's interest to stay but I can see
why people chose to leave and I'm
reminded in when I tried to put the case
for Europe I'm reminded of something
that happened to Adlai Stevenson in the
1950s when he was talking to a very
enthusiastic University or perhaps a bit
like this and one student was so
enthused he said alright nineteen people
will support you and he said that's not
enough I need a majority
that's what happened to the Europeans in
my opinion on your second on your first
point which which I'm answering second
on the elite and the people absolutely
right of course he states have been
created by elites but almost all of them
have moved in a personal period to
accommodate themselves to a world in
which deference to elites is much less
and the most obvious example is France
which established a system of direct
democracy the one I think which has
moved least towards moving towards of
people in Germany for very obvious
historical reasons and perhaps that is
why you have the AFD in the movement
away from the as it were consensual
structure you've got the same in Austria
which also established a highly
consolation of structure those systems
are under much strain because they
haven't moved towards a revolution and
Britain under Margaret Thatcher in
particular and Tony Blair I think moved
towards a much less deferential
political structure now the European
Union hasn't done that it remains in
prisons perhaps understandably is
difficult to change within the
conceptual structure launched by Rome on
a great man genius but a man of his age
and not of the modern age
I can't think because very very
obviously if you leave an institution
you don't get the benefits you had when
in it and the hopes were larger benefits
elsewhere I think I called in discussion
my last lecture Singapore on tens that
we become a global hub and free trade
it's not as easy as some people suggest
now the other countries lack the global
ties of Britain so it'd be even more
difficult for them but the some of the
BRICS it is perhaps seem to imply you
could as it will leave a tennis club
because you think the subscriptions too
high and you don't like the rules but
still continue to play on the tennis
courts on the same basis as when you
were a member of the club now clearly
you can't and if you say we'll do
something quite different fine that's
fine but that isn't what we are going to
do because obviously European Union's
our closest trading partners so you're
bound to trade on less favorable terms
and when you remember and that seems to
be a matter of logic and some of the
breaks it is implied that doesn't matter
because we can have wonderful trade
agreements with America Australia India
like now I mean again I think the result
might have been different as a referee
been held after the election of
President Trump which made it clear that
once so ain't gonna be so easy to get
trade agreements for the Americas
perhaps we hoped so identicals much in
and the problem of disentangling
yourself from all that legislation is
huge and what we've done in Britain is
to incorporate the whole of it into our
law so that Parliament can decide which
it wishes to keep which it wishes to
modify in which it wishes to repeal it's
a huge and long job and say we have
become very very entangled in into it
so I don't think there's much really
that would encourage other countries to
leave no hit the line we say he said
until we voted to me Britain's stance in
negotiating with the Europeans was give
us what we want or we will leave and
that was the basis for Margaret Thatcher
and David Cameron and others it's back
to major concessions from Europe he said
we've now put ourselves in the position
of saying give us what we want or we
will stay I think you later in fact gave
an even more colorful rendition that
they give us what we want or we'll shoot
ourselves in the actions
i but as as he said you do need a
majority not just the right mind is
rather unfortunate that they didn't pay
more attention to use in what we are
doing so now I think I really wanted
[Applause]
[Music]